Hey everyone.  Why is it illegal for a supplier to give a better deal to one business but not another?
Why should a giant chain store and a mom and pop shop pay the same price for the same product?
The answer lies in a law from 1936 that most people have never heard of, the Robinson Patman Act.
It's a piece of antitrust legislation designed to regulate price discrimination and protect small businesses.
But does it still matter today?
Let's break it down.
Back in the early 20th century, chain stores were exploding in popularity.
They had size, volume and leverage, and they used it to squeeze lower prices from suppliers.
That put small independent businesses at a massive disadvantage.
The Robinson Patman act was Congress's way of saying you can't give better prices to one buyer just because they're big.
There has to be a legitimate reason.
It amended the Clayton Antitrust act and put a sharp focus on price discrimination.
That is, when two buyers are offered different prices for the same product, even when they're buying similar amounts.
Here's the core idea.
If you're a supplier selling goods to two different buyers and they're buying like quantities and competing in the same market, you have to treat them equally in terms of price and promotional terms.
So if retailer A gets a case of soda for $10 and retailer B gets the same case for $7, retailer A may have grounds to sue if there's no lawful reason for the difference.
Now, there are some exceptions.
Sellers can charge different prices if there's a real cost difference, like transportation or volume related savings.
But those reasons must be clearly justifiable.
Let's break down this act into three different parts.
The first is primary line injury, and this is when a seller's discount hurts their competitors.
Secondly, secondary line injury when a buyer's competitors are harmed.
Think like a small store losing customers because it can't match big store prices.
And then lastly, tertiary line injury.
And this is when the consumer ultimately suffers from the inequality.
There's also a rule around promotional support.
If you're giving one buyer an ad allowance or display help, you must offer it on proportionally equal terms to everyone else.
Now let's turn to a real world example.
Let's suppose we have a soda company giving a national grocery store chain a steep discount.
Here we're going to have 30% off wholesale, but charges the local corner store full price.
That discount lets the chain undercut the local prices, drawing customers away.
If the local shop can show that this pricing hurt its ability to compete and that that price difference wasn't due to volume or shipping costs, it might be a violation of the actual this is where things get tricky.
These cases aren't always cut and dry, and proving harm isn't easy.
So what do people think about the Robinson Patman hat?
You have your supporters, you have your critics.
Supporters say it shields for small businesses.
It helps level the playing field and prevents big chains from bullying suppliers into unfair deals.
They argue it preserves choice and local economies, things that matter to real communities.
Critics, on the other hand, say it's outdated.
They argue that it punishes efficiency, discourages discounting and can actually harm consumers by preventing volume based savings from passed along as lower from being passed along as lower prices.
In fact, the FTC has rarely enforced the act in recent years, a signal that even regulators might find it tough to apply in today's fast moving globalized economy.
Does it still matter?  Robinson Patman act still exists, but in practice it's rarely used.
That could change, especially as lawmakers revisit how to handle modern giants like Amazon and Walmart.
If buyer power becomes a bigger concern, this nearly century old law could see a second life.
The bigger question In a free market economy, should size come with pricing power or should the law intervene to keep things fair?
What do you think about the Robinson Packman Act?
Is it vital protection or is it an outdated break on competition?  That's all we have.
Hope you've enjoyed it.